wie oder was geht ab hier sein magst du
jetzt willkommen zu dieser guetta und
challenge voraus hallo mein name ist
essig und junior a trap laut as i und ii
spielen heute in change die max in die
kommentare geschrieben wurde
unter welchen folge wartet der letzten
der letzten verdanken und zwar darf ich
nur jeden zweiten block nehmen also
today landrat das heißt den dass sie
nicht mitnehmen ich checke das alles ab
und ich muss letzten darfst du dir
nehmen überwacht das ist also auch
richtig auf die zu laufen als würde ich
sie nehmen ja ja genau
also du musst dir möglich sein von der
letzten position dass sie komplett zu
nehmen sonst zählt das nicht den dass du
nicht nehmen na klar ich habe gerade
mein ausgemacht wen sich ja sicher
privat ok max ist sich sicher in der
stadt gesehen
ich bin gerade auf drogen man dafür dass
du hier sind nicht neben den darf ich
nicht mit ihm muss erst mal hingehen
als mein gehen dahin jetzt auch ja auch
wirklich sagen so jetzt ab so weiter
macht sich nicht besonders genau
überlegen uns macht sicher dahin das
nichts ja aber besser als wenn ich mich
ja irgendwie so helfe den dazu nehmen
der finnische ich glaub okay bis zu
denen mitnehmen weil finnischen also
nicht mitnehmen willst du ihn nicht
mitnehmen verwenden wobei ein einspruch
ist auch das ist echt schwer 216
blockiert das kannst du sauber finde ich
glaub ich finde ich auch oder jung ist
oder irgendeine sehr schön nicht sehr
schön ich bin kalam jet 501 auf lsd für
jeden zweiten block stehen auf euch
hätte quasi bis auf bis auf die 100 grad
finnischen bekommen hätte ich es doppelt
haben können ja es stimmt
ok den apps mit denen in japan immer
ausgelacht den avaya lasst mich in ruhe
dich jemand muss auch erstmal von der
sense die das auch einen arzt an freunde
sind ganz vielen alter keine rolle hat
dann kann ich gut da komme ich nicht mal
gesehen hat ich will spricht aber so
wild entschlossen in die richtung
hier kann ich mir jede menge auslassen
irgendwann sprung von springe gerade mal
keine ausgelassene ja du hast ja gesagt
jetzt musst du zwei auslassen ich glaub
ich hab das ja erst las den aussehen
lassen für den schmerz stehen hatte ich
auch führen schmerzt darunter ist ein
team das wieder nimmt wo ich hasse das
die changes kaka hat es super derartige
spenders in der ersten runde ja aber
weißt du wenn man geld da und suchte
dann ist es nicht schön wenn man keine
blöcke liegen lassen ja ich weiss es tut
in der seele weh deswegen jetzt auch an
dieser technische rum dass du gerade
eben habe ich mitgenommen
den noch nicht mit dem einsatz verletzt
und wir müssen auch pizza bestellt kein
polster auf die pizza ich muss dich
gerade eben überreden oder ich muss sie
überzeugen dass ihre pizza bestellt
haben obwohl ich sie bezahlt habe ich
habe so eine kleine pizza pasta vision
seitdem lukrativer hat ohne wird seither
pizza mein lokal speech geht ich denke
er ist sind so viele schöne kommen wir
ja weiter die letzte genommen
denn das habe ich genau in dem würde ich
jetzt sieht man ja ja ja ja das war der
muss einfach nur mit einem sprung
möglich sein die zu erreichen dann zehn
jetzt ausgelassen
der ist jetzt wieder mein nicht meine
er musste so den nächsten dürften wir
nehmen aber sie geben
884 mehr als alle an nicht als king
player ist ein ziemlicher kind player
und hat mehr als ich erwartet habe ist
diese reihe von blöcken bitte nicht
ausgelassen
da habe ich zwei aus der versuch ist
strafbar holz hinnehmen
aber ich gebe nicht den schmerz war
viele leute das ist nicht schön dort hat
etwas von mir ich solle einfach es ist
einfach grausam den könnte sie holen
hier darfst du nicht nehmen ich bin
vollkommen inkompetent als aufpasser ich
wichtige saison ja komm lass mich in
ruhe so schön aus der rechts musste aber
hier ist papa verschärften
und weiter runter leute ist es schwierig
ich will gar nicht wissen vielleicht
will ich einfach in köln rekord
aufstellen wenn ich die gerade alle
mitnehmen würde
die runde ist sehr gut also du machst
die 1000 coins mitgeben zeiten komplett
auslassen würde ich mal sagen kann jetzt
nicht um stirbst aber abschnitt 1000 bis
2000 kölns so angefühlt als hätte ich
schon tausend mal richtig gut gewesen
hat kann ein ausgelassen wird nicht mit
damit man ist nicht ruhig aber das
reicht nicht
ja man muss sein man muss ja immer
direkt runter springt genau dich nicht
so gut sagt sie nichts mehr wieder
auslassen da unten sie sich doch
ich glaube ich die ausnahme machen nein
die an ihm vorbei aber drei runden voll
also trotz gegen kollnburg auslassen
erste die meisten kurzen ohne mit das
ist echt relativ starr 1081
ich glaub ich gehe gar nicht auf bogen
diesmal kaufen hier gelebt auf drogen
ich würde sagen die apple und münchen
geben
apple inc hany razi die ab und dämonisch
ich kann aber ich bin gut beschwert weil
sonst wenig salatic damit kann ich jetzt
zweimal in kärnten wird was gute kommen
wisst ihr leute diese momente da hast
man das spiel einfach nur immerhin
immerhin alter was war dass du das
ludwig beck und die relative ich habe es
mit oder soweit immer gibt es ca seine
ganzen konzern kommt so was beides ist
richtig bitte ok aber jetzt habe ich
abends drei das ist eigentlich barbara
54 20 level ob beck und feiert ist es
eigentlich richtig cool und lud input
habe ich nicht kann es ja wohl relativ
relativ kann man kann man rechtlich acht
formationen mit dem entspannten toppen
schwer aber ich bin echt zufrieden also
performance mäßig weil die runde relativ
stark nur jeden zweiten block nehmen ich
schon tafel eigentlich dafür finde ich
es eigentlich gute stimmung richtig gut
schwärmt gehe ich ja klar wenn jemand so
rumläuft
danach hatten hat er wahrscheinlich
alles beck ja schönheit altern stehen
fast alle player oder wird leiden
mitleiden
aber er ist auch ein ganz neuer key
player vor der hut ab allerdings pink
player was hat der verbände und pinken
fast so etwas wie ein original jetzt hab
ich dir wieder in qualität der küche
kommen wo am nächsten ist allerdings
nicht schön das einsammeln weltmeister
der herzen soft
wer das ist eine aber hier natürlich
nebenbei items aufgesammelt dich
schlagen lassen
die auch wieder im team ist scheinbar
eindeutig sowieso ein bisschen so
aussieht auch als asp welcher motivation
also ja gut dass monty und er ist sicher
nicht so ein spiel nicht einspringt
nicht ansprechen den kampf europas oft
kaum noch einer da noch einer oder alles
cool alles gut also erstmals beständig
und austauschen 12 brauche ich nicht
ja aber vielleicht hat der staat 154
israels ein account
ich finde man kann das aber eigentlich
besser machen also ich werde jede runde
wieder erkannt der tut mir leid aber wir
sind hier nicht zum screen spaß hatte
ich sehe das nicht ein laster von den
gegnern dann ist die schule abgegolten
okay ist respekt alternative sein seinen
screen noch machen
der gestalter der screen okay ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen es war relativ
tapfer aber es lief mindestens genau so
gut wie es eigentlich schwer war und
schmerzhaft ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen haben auch noch eine richtig
coole gestern change auf dem kanal von
meinem bruder gemacht da sehen wir beim
nächsten mal der knoten meine marke und
bis dahin tschüss